any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
welcome everybody to a very very special
episode of the into the impossible
podcast I have had on many professors
from Brown University where I got my PhD
I've had on many professors from the
University of Wisconsin-Madison where I
spent some time uh and uh and I've had
on a few professors from UC San Diego
and from Stanford and from Caltech but
I've never had on one from my alma mater
my beloved alma mater Case Western
Reserve University Hall of the fighting
Spartans where I attended from uh a 1989
to 1993 and we're joined by uh
contemporary of mine and in age more or
less uh Professor Stacy McGaw who was
recommended to me by his I cannot
neglect to mention the uh the the
mishpaka the family that put me in touch
with you a legend family Cal you're
watching hopefully uh you'll be you'll
be pleased to see your you know your
distant cousin who's maybe a couple
steps closer related to you than I am
anyway it's Professor Stacy McGaw who's
a renowned scientist cosmologist
astronomer rather and professor in the
department of astronomy at Case Western
uh his fields of expertise include
studying low surface brightness galaxies
Galaxy formation and their evolution as
long as as well as testing dark matter
and alternative hypotheses and he is uh
perhaps you know not not the least of
which he is known for uh making novel
predictions about the cosmic microwave
backgrounds acoustic patterns which are
near and dear to my heart as you all
know but today he's on the podcast
really to follow up and maybe expand
upon the work of his colleague and and
certainly his friend Mordecai Milgram
who was on the show this summer joined
us from Weissman Institute in the land
eres Israel in Israel and we had some a
few Audio Connections we'll still put a
link to the podcast there uh and
Mordecai showed some of Stacy's slides
and so I thought it was
um it was a due course to get Stacy on
the podcast anyway enough introduction
Stacy how are you doing how's my beloved
Cleveland Ohio uh I'm great the weather
here is perhaps not as Charming as there
but it's you know it's not really winter
yet we we had one decent snowfall but
now it's gone so okay yeah we get snow
here too it's just like you know in the
mountains and very picturesque but
um I I really appreciate you joining I
know it's been a busy week for you a lot
of uh data and and um and exciting
opportunities for you uh we're gonna
talk normally we talk to authors we ask
them about their books and what inspired
them to write books I I hope you know
maybe someday you'll write a book maybe
you'll uh uh you know kind of Honor Us
by coming back on the podcast but uh
today we're going to talk about
um kind of a synoptic overview of this
exciting uh turn of events that really I
have to say that you're you and Mordecai
and a few other Intrepid Souls Sabina
hasenfelder my friend and colleagues
Stefan Alexander
um perhaps Justin Curry other people
looking for Alternatives or explanations
that don't involve particulate dark
matter we've had on many many people
discussing dark matter and even
discussing the only form of dark matter
that I say we know for sure exists which
are neutrinos many people on Elena April
has been on kaishwani has been on so uh
Stacy I want to ask you you have a a
presentation we're going to go through
that and we're going to take we had some
audience questions we're going to ask
you those questions and uh it's going to
be a lot of fun so I really appreciate
and just a reminder you can always
subscribe to the podcast here and leave
questions for my guests uh here or on
Twitter uh I understand Stacy you're not
on Twitter as much anymore you're on
Truth social as I understand it so I'm
I I am trying to make the transformation
domestodon
um you know if you figure it out you
know go for chilling was on the podcast
this summer he wrote a book called The
Elephant in the universe yeah and so
that would be the Mastodon in the
universe so if you figure out how to do
it I have not been able to apply my my
case Western you know Spartan or my
Cleveland Guardian brain to make it work
but you are are much smarter you'll be
able to figure it out so it's it's like
uh Twitter only and Linux so you you
have to just take the plunge and then
it'll it'll come to you yeah the server
is running okay great so you have some
uh keynote slides uh that you're
graciously
um uh agreed to present and I think
it'll my audience will get a good kick
out of it especially since your audio is
already about uh 10 to the fifth times
better than uh good old Mordecai's was
well all right I'm glad to hear that
because actually uh all when we were
teaching all through covid it was an off
and on thing so I'm glad it's on it is
on it is on it's great
okay so I share my thoughts yeah please
do alrighty
this is
um these are slides I've I've basically
cripped from the last time I gave a
public talk to the physics Club down in
Akron
um and uh a title that the acceleration
discrepancy because that was the term
that Jacob beckenstein used and it's
sort of really where
uh the Dark Matter problem kicks in but
that
um goes a long way so does that work
okay for you sometimes it dies okay that
looks great okay good so I I like to
start off with the philosophical clip uh
that what gets us into trouble is not
what we don't know uh it's what we know
for sure that that just ain't showed so
um and I've heard this attributed to
Mark Twain
um Lou herrig
um I spent some time fracking it down in
there as I can tell it's a paraphrase of
Josh Billings not quite what he said but
um anyway the things we know for sure
are what Newton and Einstein taught us
and they're part of the universe is full
of non-garyonic cold dark matter
um and you know
um how did we get from A to Z there
there's a lot to it and
um this is this is what I like to call
the Dark Matter tree it's it's sort of a
sketch I made when I first had to
confront this problem in a big way so
you know I I had a normal childhood like
you I was raised to believe in dark
matter and I understand all the reasons
why that's a good idea or at least a
necessary idea and so the the sort of
the empirical roots of the problem are
there at the bottom the sort of launched
astronomical evidence that lead us to
believe in the stuff uh and then to
treat flowers into all these different
ideas and I I scribbled this and I think
it was 1995.
and
um I recently uh looked at a version
done by a um uh some particle physicists
and it actually it fits really well
um some of the names have changed but
they're really talking about the same
thing like strange nuggets are basically
generalized to be macros these days and
things like that
um so very quickly you know there are
spiral galaxy rotation curves they go
faster than they should
um there are all sorts of indications of
discrepancies and clusters of galaxies
um the gravitational lensing that you
can see is Rife in this case but also
the hydrostatic equilibrium the amount
of gravity you need to hold in the hot
intrapluster gas
um and of course the original velocity
dispersion measurements going all the
way back to his Wiki in the 30s
um so all of these things point in the
same direction that you need more mass
than meets the eye or more generally
something extra
right and so if we uh believe what
Einstein and Newton taught us and it has
to be some form of invisible Mass
but it's an assumption a really good
assumption that what they taught us is
right uh but what if it's not uh so of
course from the cosmology side of you
one really important life evidence is
large-scale structure
you see this beautiful map of uh from
the two-mass survey of where our
galaxies are on the sky so it's a whole
Sky Map sort of like looking at a map of
the Earth but looking up at the sky
every dot is one giant Galaxy uh
color-coded by its red shift so how far
away it is and you can see these huge
structures spanning across there's
really large scale structures and of
course we started from a very smooth
initial condition in the microwave
background
um and getting here from there is is
impossible unless you have some boost
like from uh some form of dark matter
uh now as an observer I would like to
prune the tree I would like to cut off
branches that are not promising or the
wrong answers and hopefully we could
narrow it down to a single uh answer and
so very quickly um some of the early
ideas were well maybe it's just some
extra normal matter that we can't see
[Music]
um Brown dwarfs or lots and lots of
Jupiters or something like that and I'll
just assert at this point we can rule
almost all of those out
um and that's been true for a long time
and you know there are little corners of
parameter space you can play with if
you'd want to ignore a big bang nuclear
synthesis but I I have to say I never to
be seriously because Big Bang nuclear
synthesis was already well established
when I was young and there just wasn't
enough Mass available in normal matter
to make up the dark matter that we
needed
um so then there was a great idea of
neutrinos
um I remember hearing a talk behind beta
in the 80s where he suggested neutrinos
could have mass and and I was an
undergraduate at the time who'd just
been taught that neutrinos didn't have
mass and that would screw everything up
and so I was like well that can't be
but then I had the the realization well
maybe if it's true that would that would
surely be the answer
um and of course now we know it is true
and it's not the answer so there's
there's mass and neutrinos but but it's
just not enough to explain what we need
um and so by a long way running the most
uh favored answer for a long time it's
been some form of cold dark matter
um which usually is attributed to some
uh fundamental new particle and and for
a long time the most popular and
certainly one that was convincing to me
uh was the wimp the weekly interacting
massive particle from supersymmetry uh
from the astronomical perspective it
doesn't have to be that but it does have
to have some uh important
characteristics
um and motivation is one as I already
mentioned big by nucleosynthesis this is
the mass density in terms of the
critical uh that you infer from all the
different Light Elements won't go into
that many detail uh but that is
consistently less than what we get for
the gravitating mass density so there's
stuff out there that seems to be
gravitating that is not normal matter
[Music]
uh and the other thing as we also
already mentioned is that you need to go
from that very smooth initial condition
of the microwave background where these
little fluctuations are are only a part
in 100 000 uh to these really huge
structures where there's vast amounts of
empty space and then boom a lot of
structure uh and and gravity will do
that for you it'll make the uh the rich
get richer and so the little
fluctuations will get bigger over time
uh but it's also a weak force that takes
a long time to do that there just isn't
enough time in the 14 billion years the
universe is to get here from there uh
unless you do something to boost the
process uh and that something can be
some form of new particle as long as it
does not interact directly with the
photons and just through gravity uh so
that's that's the cold dark matter
and I was a big believer and proponent
of that for many years
um
until
um I had reasons to doubt it
um and one of the things that I find a
lot of people struggle with is that it
must be this way because we're taught
and even I just got done teaching
cosmology and I thought that it must be
what this way because that's what we do
right but I teach it as I had Barbara
riding on sorry to interrupt by Barbara
rodden on the podcast last year and
she's written the book that's been read
by more you know undergraduates that
I've taught from it for decades uh she's
an esteemed colleague
um yeah we don't really talk about mom
there's a sentence about Mom but
sentence about Alternatives there's more
in kind of the wind Miracle maybe you
could say something about the wit
Miracle are you going to mention that
just as I wasn't for time but I I
certainly can just in a couple sentences
what do people mean when they I mean
when you hear the phrase the wimp
Miracle so so certainly one of the
things maybe I do have something about
that
um
yeah so so the miracle was that we
needed this extra stuff
and and in fact I used Barbara
Brighton's cosmology textbook and of
course I just taught and so you know we
we were convinced I was convinced by
this argument that you know you need
this extra stuff and all the particles
that you know about are in thermal
equilibrium early on and then at some
point as the universe expands and cools
off the freezes out
and if you ask what you need to to
um you know what would happen if there
were something some particle that only
interacted through the weak nuclear
force and not through photons well then
The Relic abundance of that would be
about right to be the dark matter so
these wimps that was miraculous right
there were just orders and Orders of
magnitude of of what the right
interaction scale would be to give you
the right answer and they were
coincident with the one force that we
knew about and so uh it was it was a
miracle and I found that uh very
convincing
um of course since then people have been
working hard to find those particles
um and have not been successful so the
earliest this is a uh the sort of
um figure of Merit that shows the
interaction cross-section of uh these
lamps how they interact weekly with
nuclei uh and uh their Mass which
initially was thought to be around 100
GED
um though that's really unknown and
people broaden their Horizons as to what
they're willing to consider uh for that
um but that sort of upper region was the
original prediction
um and that was ruled out by uh 2008
which I call out because
um some colleagues here this is before
I'd even come to the case I was at
University of Maryland at the time but I
I participated in a conference here uh
organized by Glenn starkman and um Tom
shot and Dan Akram
um actually that reminds me I did lie
I'm sorry Glenn starkman was uh did a
did a podcast before so you're not the
first Case Western so sorry Stacy we can
end the interview now if you like please
continue I forgot all about my good
friend Glenn sorry Glenn's an obvious
person to talk to so yeah that's good
um so yeah so so we had this meeting
here and um you know you can see there
was some moving at the goal posts that
the new prediction was at blue and green
blob and I become skeptical by then so I
was like well you know how much of the
probabilities in that head and how much
in the tail because you can see there's
a long tail the lower cross section and
so far up until that point
the history of the subject had been the
experimentalists pushing down their
limits more and more and and the
theorists kind of ducking moving to goal
posts and so I was afraid that would
happen again and and at the time the
speaker assured me yell now with 98 of
the probability is up there in that head
and uh we'll find it um pretty soon well
that's not what happened
um and at this point basically all that
area is excluded
um so wimps were a great idea as well
super Symmetry and there's just no
evidence for them at this point
um and so you can go a couple of ways
and say well there are lots of other
things the Dark Matter might be uh and
that's true and it's also hard to
make up good candidates candidates that
were as good as wimps
um or you can say well geez maybe
there's maybe we were wrong to assume
that we infer dark matter because we
assume gravity works the same on all
scales that's not right right uh and so
that was really
um what came up in my own work
um galaxies are these important
keystones in the whole problem at the
modern era of dark matter really took
off in the late 70s early 80s with uh
Ruben and Albert osma's observations of
flat rotation curves
um you know one can argue all the way
back to the 30s from the work of John
Urich and uh for slicky
um but nothing really happened with it
until then now we've snowballed into
this huge Paradigm that involves cold
dark matter
and uh there's a lot more to it now than
what we understood at the time we knew
there was dark matter so we needed uh
sorry we knew there were flat rotation
cursely infer that we talked matters you
take that Galaxy You observe it and the
actual rotation is flat where the sort
of the normal matter predicts that
declining rotation curve I can't that's
something that's used systematically in
hundreds of galaxies now I can so
oh sorry yeah I was just going to say
um I can't resist as is my speaker or my
host prerogative is uh is to let's see
if I can get this to work no it won't
work interesting all right let's see if
that'll work no
[Music]
um anyway I'm showing to the slides if
you're watching on YouTube this is a
rotation curve uh sorry this is a galaxy
image taken by Margaret Burbage wow
that's great and the reason that's
significant is that she then took a
spectrum of the same object which I'm
showing here these glass plates from the
1960s when a scientist by the name of
Vera Rubin was here at UC San Diego
working with Margaret and Jeff Burbage
learning the techniques that Stacy was
just showing so I'm really thrilled to
have a connection to uh to these great
Titans of astronomy and cosmology uh
although Jeff was uh not a fan not only
of dark matter but of all of modern
cosmology as you know but Margaret was
very sober and exceptional astronomer of
the highest caliber right
so yeah um and and I had caused to look
up not too long ago that um Urban and
Reuben collaborated a lot in the 60s
yeah to do this kind of work and they
didn't really detect the you could they
detected something they didn't quite get
far enough out to see the flatness until
uh the 70s and I I was just there
looking through my slides because I
often have some of those historic slides
from uh Vera where you know basically
she'll have the spectrum that you showed
and then she had taken a picture of the
Reflection from the slit jaw so you can
see the Galaxy and where the slit cut
across it and I I don't have that in
this presentation unfortunately but um
but yeah and so this has been known for
a long time and
um since since we mentioned it on one of
Vera's favorite stories uh was that when
she first showed the flat rotation curve
of Andromeda to Alan Sandage
um he said well that's just the effect
of of looking at a really bright Galaxy
and she was like what does that mean you
know and and and it means that even
really smart people say some pretty
silly things when they're confronted
with evidence that they don't get
um and so Vera went out and observed 100
more galaxies and they all did the same
thing and then okay that's that's what
the universe does yeah
um and so this is what was no uh so so I
would make the sociological comment that
when the Dark Matter Paradigm as we now
know it really took off in the 80s
that was what was new you had flat
rotation curves you need something to
make up that excess and early in that
time you didn't need a lot of extra mass
and so so it was reasonable at first to
think okay you have a lot of brown
dwarfs or something
um and then it kind of snowballed well
it's not just a factor of two it's a
factor of 10. now you're breaking the
nuclear synthesis limits and you have to
invent some new kind of particles and
then there was this kind of shotgun
marriage between uh the astrophysics of
galaxies and cosmology with with
particle businesses were like oh yeah we
can provide those
um and so
you know what we knew then was that
rotation purpose are flat and you needed
something extra
and it snowballed from there
there's more to the story
um and there's a lot of order to the
data
um and so this is a bunch of rotation
curves of galaxies of different mass
and really big uh massive galaxies
rotate fast and lower mascalities rotate
slowly uh and so those things I label
those gas dominated low surface
brightness galaxies are the kind of
things that I was working on
um and it really surprised me the extent
to which these followed the the rules
I'm going to describe
um there was this thing called the
television relation which was also
discovered in the 70s and it was used
heavily as a distance indicator it's a
sort of an empirical correlation between
Alpha brighter Galaxy was and how fast
it spun
um
going over a lot of lot of work I've
worked on this a lot every time I think
I'm done with it it drags me back in
um but to make that long story short the
the fundamental physical correlation
seems to be between the mass of what you
can see both stars of gas uh and that
flat rotation curve not any random
measure but specifically the flat part
of the rotation curve
um and so I call that the baryonic
politicial relation because it depends
on all the baryony mass the normal
matter that we can actually see and
those little dinky LSB galaxies fall
right on the same relation which just
surprised the heck out of me for a
couple reasons one they're more gas than
stars and if you correct for that you
add them together then they're right on
so that actually makes sense uh the part
that doesn't make sense is that flat
part of the rotation in the bright
galaxies it's got a contribution both
from the dark matter and from the Stars
you can't neglect the terms where we see
it
these flow service brightness galaxies
are basically Like You Yank away the
stars and so you would think they would
have somewhat less velocity while other
things being equal and that's not
observed and that's what really first
made me concerned I came up with all
sorts of conventional models for why
that might be true
uh and they all I found I was always
engaging in some tautologies assuming
something to make it so and it still
confuses me to this day how we can
explain this relation uh conventionally
with dark matter
um but just in an empirical sense you
can note that uh the Galaxy's awful lot
along the line of constant acceleration
and that's a theme that comes up again
um if you want to make rotation curves
flat
um it's basically
related to this scale and so it comes up
in terms of the Tully fissure relation
um and then my contribution was focused
on high and on low service brightness
Galaxy so just a quick description
um Heights or if it's brightness
galaxies these are you know there's a
nice pretty picture of the Spiral those
are his brightness of galaxies are the
same but the stars are more spread out
and so you can barely notice them uh and
so I was attracted Milky Way uh high
surface brightness Galaxy
Milky Way is pretty high surface
brightness that's right and so the the
story most of his brightness Galaxy that
you're seeing there on the screen it's
Central service brightness near the
middle is about the same as what we are
at the Solar Circle way out from the
center of the Milky Way
um and so you know you can zoom in and
there's not much to see but then you can
take a high contrast image and here I've
turned up the gain so you can see uh the
low surface brightness Galaxy and when
you can do that you see diameter is
comparable the distance is comparable
which is like why I picked these pairs
is about the same size but the stars are
much more spread out
uh and so this uh now is going to
quantify why I thought there should be a
shift of these galaxies off of the Tully
fish relation that Newton told us that
the velocity scales with the mass and
the radius uh these things these low
surface brightness Galaxies for a given
mass of stars have a bigger radius
they're more spread out
so you would think whatever the
contribution that the stars make to be
flat and you can adjust that in your
models but they make some contribution
and so you'd expect some shift uh as you
lower the surface density of the stars
and so each color here is a a different
bin of surface brightness going lower
and lower and as I went to lower and
lower surface brightness they did not
shift
as I predicted so those lines are what I
predicted and so I was really annoyed
this was my prediction
um it'll Convent perfectly conventional
dark matter based prediction and you
know I could have fudged anything right
at this point you say okay well I was
attributing too much to the Stars so the
shift should be less and then he's like
I said you start doing tautological
things to make it work out and basically
I could have
explained anything but what I I just
didn't make because there's a there's a
fine too right you have to balance the
Dark Matter contribution against the
Luminous contribution as you're taking
out the you know spreading out the Stars
you have to sort of backfill the dark
matter
uh and so it's that fine-tuning that
really got me concerned with the the
if it was right right this is this is
you know a hard thing to know if it's if
there's invisible mask how do you know
to doubt it uh and fine-tuning problems
pretty much the worst thing you can
encounter but it gets worse so this is
just one pair of galaxies plucked off of
that plot and they have the same flat
velocity within the errors
um and the same total baryonic mass so
you could not tell them apart on the
Tully Fisher diagram
so now you plot out their actual
rotation curves and you can see there's
a big difference in the shape uh and
that's because there's a big difference
in the concentration of stars so one way
to explain your way out of the lack of
shift in poly fissure which is to say
okay the star is way so little it
doesn't matter at all it's just the dark
matter but if you do that then you're
basically predicting that the rotation
curve shape should be just the Dark
Matter everywhere
and that's not right these things are
the same math same d flat they should
have the same rotation curve and they do
not and they do not in a way that
clearly depends on how concentrated the
stars are the more concentrated the
Stars the faster the rotation curve
Rises and vice versa uh this is
sometimes referred to as diversity of
rotation curves each day and that
diversity goes away if you consider the
size of the disc so here this is actual
length kiloparsecs meters whatever
length scale you want
um here you can fit some functional form
to describe the disk and they sort of
really fall in line and that's one of
the systematics that that has emerged
since the systematic and the plot
rotation curves was first discovered so
whatever's going on it it somehow knows
about the distribution of the Starlight
not just the total mass but how it's
spread out
um and so that's something that we have
to explain no matter what that's an
empirical fact
um it also seems to do with that
acceleration scale I mentioned before
um here are the rotation curves of a
whole bunch of galaxies from the spark
project that uh federicanelli it was a
postdoc here lad
um and the uh rotation curves have been
uh color coded by the surface brightness
of the stars and so you can see by
saying high surface brightness galaxies
of high accelerations those surface
brightness Galaxies have low
accelerations and so what you get does
follow from what you see just not in the
way that Newton predicts foreign
and so you can quantify that a bit more
this is what we call the central density
relation and there's a particular scale
of surface density where
um this discrepancy sets in so up above
here what you see really is what you get
in the high surface brightness regime
galaxies with bright bulges pretty much
the Stars dominate the mass budget and
that's all you need you wouldn't for the
need for dark matter but you get further
out of course rotation curves flatten
out and and for these low surface
brightness galaxies you need dark matter
or something even a small radii and so
there is a a break there and this is
what I say when it's predictive that
color encoding basically is Quantified
by this so the color is referring to
that surface
foreign
and so it's not just the center it's
your uh perceptive audience members will
have noticed it's all along the rotation
curve that this happens and so uh the
quantity again that really seems to
matter is the acceleration so on the top
row I've got a few galaxies with their
rotation curves the black points are
what's observed the blue lines or what
you expect from what you see
and they're very different right you see
a lot of diversity in the actual
rotation curves but then below that is a
part of the centripetal acceleration B
squared over R that's observed there uh
against the what's predicted from The
observed baryonce so we we see the mass
and stars in The Gas We can solve
Newton's equation uh the poisson
equation to predict what the
acceleration should be and if it were
one to one it would just be that dashed
line
uh and it's not and that excess
um in velocity shows up as an excess in
uh acceleration but the remarkable thing
is that these very different galaxies
end up following very much the same line
in this acceleration plane so there's
something important about accelerations
[Music]
um and so in fact you could put all the
galaxies on um the same plot and just
bend them up because you can't really
tell the difference within the errors uh
and and this is what we were hoping to
check when when
um Federico first made this plot I
happened to walk by his office it's like
Stacy you'll have to see this
um and I walk in and I was just amazed
because we expected there would be some
outliers because that's what always
happens with astronomical data but if
you take just a little bit of care and
excluding the data that you know are no
good
um there's stuff at this they all fall
on top of each other so there's
something really systematic going on
and it's it's worth remembering that
that dotted line there that is what
Newton predicts so if there were no dark
matter no funny business just what you
saw was what you get everything would
fall on that line
everything does fall on a relation it's
just not that line of mutants
um and so this acceleration scale keeps
coming up in these different ways the
central density relations television
relations radio acceleration relation
this is a plot from uh federican
Valley's recent review in nature
um so
empirically this acceleration scale is
in the data it's something we have to
explain in any Theory
um and it's only at really low
accelerations that this happens so I
made this the ratio this be analysis the
discrepancy how much sort of effect you
need how much dark matter you need and
it's only at really low accelerations
that this kicks up
you know we understand things at much
higher accelerations really well we live
here 11 orders of magnitude higher than
the effect in galaxies uh and you can go
right the way up to emerging black holes
and you know our theory of gravity seems
to work fine there but you get down to
galaxies and clusters you notice
clusters are not quite on the same
relation but that's where the Dark
Matter effect comes in so that
acceleration scale is is critical
um and so this brings us to modi's
Theory these these systematic Trends are
present in the data regardless of theory
uh but Milgram had hypothesized that
geez maybe instead of an invoking dark
matter we should change the force law
um and so
um that sounds crazy and it looks crazy
um and many people tried this in a
length scale say well galaxies are much
bigger than the solar system so so maybe
something changes in between those
scales we can exclude that that does not
work
um but what Milgram suggested is that
maybe it's not a length scale maybe it's
an acceleration scale and he did that a
long time ago in 1983
um and so he knew then that rotation
curves were flat this was a way to make
them flat so that was the motivation
just like for Dark Matter uh but then
once you write down the fourth law
you're really stuck with it and a lot of
strong predictions follow
uh and so when I was struggling with
this fine-tuning problem that I
described uh I happened to hear a talk
from him and I almost didn't go I was
like notify gravity he wants to hear
that nonsense you know
um and I went and not knowing that I was
in the audience who I was or what I did
he basically in a few lines predicted
everything that I was seeing that was
confusing me
so I I described my jaw off the floor
and went back and actually looked up his
papers and actually read them uh and I
found this this remarkable passage that
that disc galaxies uh with low surface
brightness provide particularly strong
tests and you know my my bias in favor
of Dark Matter was still so strong that
when I read that I was like great I now
have the data for to that will falsify
this stupid Theory I I remember thinking
that
um because I was just now pioneering the
exploration of these low service
brightness galaxies uh more than a
decade after he had written down these
predictions
um so a lot of these data especially
those for LSP galaxies the little
surface process things simply were not
available to inform his thinking when he
made these predictions
well the first thing I realized is and
this is what he had derived on the board
basically that that blew me away it was
a tolly Fisher relation should
you know have the slope that it's was
observed to have a normalization that
depended on his acceleration scale uh he
was the first one to suggest that
um that it was fundamentally a relation
between what you see and what you get
and it didn't matter if it was stars or
a gas it was the mass of all the normal
matter
um and the thing that really got me was
that there should be no dependence on
the surface brightness that that are in
Newton's term drops out when you change
the force along this way and that's what
really got me uh because I couldn't
understand this effect at the time
conventionally in terms of dark matter
and oh that's just what's supposed to
happen yeah in this Theory
um he made other specific predictions
um that if you were to calculate the the
master light ratio in a conventional way
that would depend on radius so these are
the high surface brightness galaxies and
you can see the massive light ratio
going up as you go further out in radius
but as you go to lower surface
brightness you're going to lower
acceleration in his theory so the
discrepancy should set in sooner and be
stronger and that's what we were seeing
all right so the statement that low
surface brightness galaxies are dark
matter dominated that that came as a
surprise to me I didn't expect that none
of us expected that except Pilgrim that
was built into his theory
um is there a you know uh mechanistic
way to to see that in an acceleration
you know in in a universe where there's
Dark Matter gas or you know ordinary
matter I mean would you and you know
would you first go towards a mechanism
to change modify the acceleration law I
mean it seems almost counterintuitive
that you get actual honest-to-goodness
astrophysics you know gastrophysics
implications from changing you know
Newton's Newton's laws but am I am I
putting a cart before the horse or or
you know is it is it a correlation or or
is it you know like the Tully Fisher we
said you know the implications sort of
it's it might just be you know a
correlation but we don't understand the
causation but is this is this you know
really distinct
um like would you have gotten this if
you just told Newton about this would
would he have predicted this profit no
he would not right I see
um and and that's what I had been
struggling with you had to invoke
various topological effects in order to
make it so and that's commonly what's
done today whenever you hear about
talking people talking about feedback
and galaxies it's basically being
invoked as a deus ex machina to make it
so but that's not what we predicted a
natural prediction for uh the Lambda CDM
universe that comes out of a
cosmological observations would be that
dark matter Halos have nfw like Halos
right there's a specific functional form
and then you would add some baryons to
that and then that's what we should
observe and that's not what we observe
that's not equal to
uh mod and basically modern like
behavior is what we observe
um
you know and so to skip ahead a little I
would say that you know basically the
fourth law is unique and for the
effective Force law and galaxies looks
like mod
and so
the thing that bugs me is that why
should that happen in a dark matter
Universe it's sort of like saying oh
well the solar system is really run by
an inverse Cube law it just looks all
the time like an inverse Square law
because the dark matter is arranged just
so
that's incredibly fine-tuned and that's
basically what we have to end up doing
to explain Galaxy data with dark matter
you can do it if you're comfortable with
that fine tuning
you know go to town but
um there is no more clear sign that
we're on the wrong road in that fine
tuning because once we've convinced
ourselves that this invisible Mass
exists it's it's practically impossible
to classify it all right how do we how
do we disabuse ourselves uh that we've
gone down even even not detecting it you
know is not ground exactly right you
could also I mean that's why I was sort
of skeptical of of the the cross
sections just ever moving to goal posts
it's like well you can move that down to
zero right it's it's just right and
eventually it'll be unfalsifiable
because you'll end up in a regime where
the Supernova neutrino background will
prevent you from ever making progress
and by the way Stacy the same thing
could happen with me and looking for B
mode polarization it could be that
inflation did take place but at a very
low energy scale impossible for
experimentalists to ever to detect and
yet we can't rule out Alternatives as
well uh things like bouncing or cyclic
models of past Gas and Aegis Neil turox
and Paul steinhardt so
um so yeah I mean that's maybe uh part
two will do someday on sociology of when
you can't falsify something I mean do
you rely on them social proof and you
know going on Twitter or Mastodon
but you know lately things of um of you
know there have been a Resurgence of
interest in extremely low surface
brightness objects right things like
dragonfly can you talk about are those
challenges to to mod
um as some have suggested in the
audience um you know offline you know
what what do you say about the dark
matter you know free galaxies and the
Dark Matter only Galaxy and by the way I
don't mean any insult or anything I'm
just saying that's what they're called
in the in the in the popular imagination
I'm not saying no no that's fine so
it's it's a lot right every single
Galaxy is a test and so you have to look
at it on its own merits
um and so when df2 first came out
um I
um you know basically we did demand
analysis and the data even though it was
close to consistent with no Dark Matter
it was also consistent with them on
prediction
um at the opposite extreme examples like
dragonfly 44 which had a much too high
velocity dispersion and I remember
thinking when it first came out I didn't
even try it just looked at and said well
that's that's wrong if it's if if that's
right then mod is wrong
um since that time the measurement has
has come down to within consistency with
long
and so I think the the ultra diffuse
galaxies as we're calling these objects
are at the same stage that the low
surface brightness galaxies I worked on
in the 90s were at the same stage that
what bird bridge and Reuben were doing
in the 60s and that as the data improved
I predict that they will revert to the
mean that is defined by all the other
galaxies which also happens to look like
Bond so I I already have seen that
happen for df2 and df44 whether that
will also happen for the other ones I I
don't know right and you have to take
that as it goes but I will say that
I've been doing this for a long time now
and so I've spent an enormous amount of
time over the last quarter Century
chasing up this example or that and
it almost always not always considered a
clusters like um uh the boa cluster I
think that's a real problem for monk but
um this is a theory that people love to
hate and yeah what do you think of that
I mean I don't like to always get into
sociology I've had on me I've had on
controversial thinkers and the past
guests of all different political and
academic Stripes but what do you make of
um of of the ferocity and almost the
dismissiveness you know that that this
can't be true because you know a we
learned it in our textbooks uh B uh and
and often I should say I you know people
like Barbara Ryan she's not a militant
you know dark matter you know adherent
but uh but talk about the bullet cluster
I hear that all the time oh it's almost
like a for you know an excuse to stop
thinking right um and that's never a
good sign in science no matter what your
stripes are right so talk about the
bullet cluster to what extent in a court
of you know scientific law Law whatever
that means
um is it is it is it useful is it this
positive because you strike me as
somebody who certainly would be willing
to be proven wrong I mean you've had
many opportunities to be proven wrong
you've staked a lot on this
um it seems to me that people like you
and even people like Paul steinhardt
who's got radical alternative views
would be more than happy to find out I
was wrong they don't think it's likely
and maybe you don't either but talk
about the bullet cluster Stacy if you
would well so so let me State first that
I think one should State criteria that
would make you change your mind right so
I've done that and I can restate those
if you like but to answer your question
about the bullet cluster I think it's a
problem
uh for all theories and so it's one of
the reasons I don't actually think
there's a right answer that we know here
yet
um and it is
uh sign of the sociology that it is so
often portrayed as a problem for lawn
which it is but not also a problem for
Lambda CDM which it is also right I mean
the velocities in the bull cluster are
far higher than you'd expect as I
understand and I'm not an expert exactly
that's a key critical Lacuna in the uh
Dark Matter particulate Dark Matter
Paragon yeah um let me ask another
question so um so it is a challenge but
a challenge for both but that's kind of
you know as they say on Twitter what
about ISM you know like sure
uh so from the perspective let me ask a
more general question
um if if mod let's say God tells you or
you know Gaia tells you government is
true could it be that Monde is only true
on the scale of galaxies but not on
clusters and not on planets it's not a
possibility I sure hope not I know I
know we hope not but
um you know it's conceivable and so
there are people like and you know
Bennett who are considering these
neutrino hot dark matter you know
sterile neutrinos combined with Bond and
you mentioned Justin Glory who has his
superfluid Dark Matter model and so
they're sort of Hybrid models that do
the right thing Dark Matter wise on
large scales and long-like behavior and
galaxies
um I will admit I have a philosophical
distaste for such Hybrid models it feels
like the the tyconic solution to you
know the the old the original Scientific
Revolution it's it's not you know the
sun's still at the center but you know
well the Earth's still in center but all
the plants go around the sun and the Sun
goes around us and it's
um
well we don't know right I think we
don't know and I think the important
thing is as you said is to keep an open
mind and to be informed all by all the
data and so you know I tried this
exercise of putting on different hats
and so like I said I just got done
teaching cosmology and if I put on my
cosmology hat I look at the microwave
background and large scale structure and
all the usual things and I said it must
be that way we must have cold dark
matter right and then if I put on my
Galaxy Dynamics hap and I say well yeah
but we have an acceleration scale we
have a periodic toy situation we have
the radial acceleration relation we have
the ability to make the predictions for
individual galaxies that we see
um then I think well then it must be Mom
right because Monde is the only theory
that I've been able to use to to make uh
all priori predictions for what what
we're seeing so just just an example and
this relates back to your question about
the ultra diffuse Galaxy so a decade ago
not quite um people were doing a survey
around Andromeda and they discovered all
these these new dwarf galaxies very low
surface brightness things and I realized
there was an opportunity to test them on
because once they found them they told
me how luminous it was I could use that
information and mod but on anything else
really to predict the Velocity
dispersions in these galaxies and mod
was the one that worked right so there
are a bunch of different observations so
the velocity dispersion for each and
only one two three
um is written out here and then the mon
predictions
came true and almost all those things
those are the green circles
uh the one case that didn't come true is
Andromeda five and so this is like
the ultra diffuse things
um yeah there's one that's way off
but why did mod work in all these other
cases uh that's really the question I've
been asking for a long time that I
haven't heard people answer because they
get to pull a cluster and they get the
answer they want oh look at that wrong
with the five the whole thing is wrong
um and like you say it shuts down
discussion
um because okay I know it's wrong so I
don't have to even think about it and
it's hard to think in those different
terms so I get that
um but a lot of these things were all
priori predictions right I could look at
the thing and I could say ahead of time
what the velocity dispersion would be
and those predictions came through
that's that's what science is supposed
to do right and so I I guess my takeaway
is that there has to be this
phenomenology that we're calling Bond
it's telling us something and Milgram
discovered something fundamental he
wrote down a force law that approximates
some deeper truth
that deeper truth might be some grander
theory of gravity it might be something
about the nature of dark matter it it
does not come naturally out of whole
dark matter I would I've struggled for
years to make that true and I would
really love to be able to say that's
true so I could have to stop having this
kind of argument with everybody uh who I
should be friends with right
um but it's it's you know and there are
plenty of theorists to say oh yeah we
can explain that and our models will but
you couldn't until I told you that's
what the data said right and that's
finally react to you right no no so
anyway I mean it's just an incredibly
Rich phenomenology
um that we are not really it well it
wasn't built into our models to begin
with all we knew was that we needed more
mass rotation curves are flat we need
something extra
that's not good enough right we need to
explain why mod happens in some very
detailed ways and maybe it doesn't in
some cases and that would tell us that
bond is wrong
but we still have to explain why it
happens in all these other cases and we
don't right now and just saying it's
dark matter and some amount of
gastrophysics is is the very picture of
an unsatisfactory Theory right
very good well this has been a great
treat a great thrill
um fun to talk about yeah it's fun to
talk about maybe um if you want to stop
this live show for one moment I want to
ask you uh well I want to ask you we
have time for one experiment uh one
existential question I usually ask for
uh but in the interest of time in a late
uh academic quarter semester
um we'll only ask one but before I do
there's been a lot of talk in the media
and actually I have two or three videos
I'll link over here over there uh with
various uh folks and colleagues about
claims that the Big Bang never happened
uh because of the properties of medium
surface brightness galaxies observed by
jwst and of course this was also known
or claimed to be known by a gentleman by
the name of Eric Lerner who's got his
own YouTube channel lppf Fusion I think
it is not too far from Cleveland but
anyway all their their he believes that
the Big Bang never happened and he has
for some time uh since Hubble Deep Field
which maybe tells you something about
maybe confirmation bias I don't know but
anyway he claims that the rotation
curves and well developed morphology of
spiral galaxies at 400 million years
post Big Bang is a fatal flaw in the Big
Bang now obviously
um I don't well first of all I shouldn't
you know kind of comment before you
comment so I like your opinion uh you
know the problem with these people is
that they always compare themselves to
this guy Galileo the observational
astronomer or worse yet uh Stacy
never compare yourself to Giordano Bruno
I don't care who how good you are
um but uh but Tommy says what do you
think of the new measurements um that
went originally Panic at The discos or
you know uh jwst and we've had on uh
people uh to discuss that but what's
your opinion you're you're you know
exceptionally qualified to comment on a
if the Big Bang never happened or B if
jdst results how many bearing on Lambda
CDM which I think would be very
interesting to get your point of view on
so so first I I think the Big Bang
happened I I don't I haven't seen
anything to make it me question my my
fundamental faith of course you do
you're paid by big cosmology Stacy I am
as Upton Sinclair said you it's
impossible to get a man to think
contrary of something that his job
depends on him believing himself
if if I were following that then it's
called dark matter it's not just right
and so so I do want to make that
distinction that there's nothing in mon
that obviously contradicts that we live
in an expanding Universe in the broad
outlines of the of the Big Bang or even
details like the early Universe results
like big bang nuclear synthesis
um yeah so early that the universe is
not in the low acceleration regime so
everything should be normal
um now these jwsg results are extremely
interesting and I don't think they
contradict the Big Bang in any way I do
think they pose a problem for a Lambda
CDM and it's structure formation
Paradigm as we currently understand it
um as you know very well we have to go
from that incredibly smooth initial
condition indicated by the microwave
background to a rich amount of structure
now and and it's it's slow going
and what jwsd seems to be seeing is that
really big galaxies appeared quite early
in the universe within the first half
billion years or so and that is much
sooner than was anticipated in Lambda
CDN
um so it's certainly a problem for our
structured formation Paradigm that's I
would make that distinction from The Big
Bang in general
um and I I will say that that Bob
Sanders using mon predicted that way
back in 1998 he said because so
basically you have to wait till the
coupling around Richard to 200
um up until that uh structure
information in mind is delayed because
there's no Dark Matter to give it a head
start but once you get past that the the
normal matter suddenly finds itself in
really low acceleration regime and it
acts as if there's just dogs of dark
matter and it forms uh galaxies very
quickly
so he explicitly said that there would
be uh l-star galaxies forming at reach
of 10.
um and this was in 1998 that that paper
was coming yeah
um so so I think there's a a prospect of
a real test here of course we have to
confirm what jwsd is seeing
um and that it's not just those or
galaxies are big but they're common
enough to be a problem for Lambda CDM
we have to make sure we've done the
Lambda CDM predictions right and I think
we have but you know there are always
knobs we can tune
um but hopefully there's there's a real
test there
um and and one did make a protection and
and it is consistent with that so you
don't have to throw out the whole big
bang but it may challenge the uh the
structure formation Paradigm another
quick uh point that your uh listeners
might be interested in that regard is
neutrino masses right the deploying
satellite
and the normal structure formation
Paradigm puts a pretty hard upper limit
of 0.12 EV on a solid nutrient of acids
the minimum is 0.06 from you know the
observed oscillations
and you know the problem with mon is not
making structure early it's it's not
over producing structure
um by Z equals zero so it might help to
have a little bit of neutrino Mass it
might help things like the Ebola cluster
of neutrinos had a bigger mask yeah
Katrine is only down to 0.8 EB so
that's another test if if the the
neutrino mass is somewhere in between
then that's that would be really clear
well with the Simon's Observatory uh we
aim to get to the minimum Mass level at
about three sigma and the minimum asset
level by uh set by nutrient oscillation
experiments the minimum mass as Stacy
mentioned uh so we'd get you know three
sigma on that um which with cosmology
now we'll have to have a follow-up on
whether or not you know astronomers or
sorry particle physicists will accept
the measurement of an elementary
particle the last one whose Mass we
don't know of all 17 of those little
buggers
um uh but in the remaining negative
minute uh that we have I always ask
existential questions most of which are
prompted by my uh the namesake of the
Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination that I am the associate
director of at UC San Diego uh we only
have time for one and that is equip a
quote
um he said many things one is uh one of
my favorites is um for every expert
there's an equal and opposite X expert
so you'd have to make a a you know a mon
version of that uh modified Newtonian
quit but anyway the one I want to ask
you about is uh relevant to
um to his one of his laws which is that
when an elderly but distinguished
scientist says something is possible he
or she is almost certainly right but
when they say something impossible and
this podcast called into the impossible
uh but they say something is impossible
they are most certainly wrong I want to
ask you Stacy
um what if anything would you say you've
been wrong about uh that you've changed
your mind about in recent years
[Music]
and it could be you know inside or
outside of science but I'm curious for
my listeners well certainly dark matter
right I mean I was a big believer in
dark matter and and having milgram's
predictions come true in my data uh
really caused me that kind of
existential questioning and I remember
spending nights awake staring at the
ceiling how could this come true
um and you know it did make me admit
that maybe I had been wrong to believe
so intensely that the answer had to be
dark matter
um same thing happened with the bullet
cluster when it was first announced uh
when the microwave background got out to
the third Peak
um those were both things that looked
more natural in dark matter so I was
like okay maybe I was wrong to put so
much Credence and Pilgrim having had its
predictions come true
um and so right now I'm kind of
despondent
because it seems like everything is
falsified
um and and we're not even really as a
community I don't feel like we're really
grappling with some of the most
fundamental problems meaning that if mod
is wrong is a theory
it all we're doing to explain it is oh
there's some gastrophysics and it sort
of works out and this is an answer that
we not would not accept in a junior lab
project from our undergraduates you know
um it's it's more fundamental than that
that's right
well uh Professor Stacy McGaw of the uh
renowned institution known as Case
Western Reserve University my alma mater
my heart will always be with the I
forget our theme song but I'm sure I'm
sure you could you could sing it
um those from MIT
um
yes go Guardians right here exactly I
actually got to see both of them play
and uh you should know one last bit of
trivia for you uh Stacy is that uh
because the Guardians formerly known as
a different name uh they because they
want to raise that left San Diego as the
only major city in the United States
without a single sports championship in
any sport that we've been involved with
we came close this year with the Padres
but I always say Stacy you know the
hardest job in the world is being a San
Diego sportscaster but the easiest job
is being a meteorologist okay I want to
wish you a wonderful end of your
semester happy holidays I hope you come
back on for a part two in the New Year
and I wish you all the best thank you so
much fun thank you thank you bye Stacy
bye-bye
[Music]